هجوم اوكراني يقابله صد روسي وقصف لمناطق
تقول روسيا انها معاقل ومخازن للاسلحه
والمعدات خريطه تطورات الميدانيه نبداها
من مدينه بريانسكا الروسيه التي تصدت
دفاعاتها الجويه لهجوم اوكرانيا
بالمسيارات الصهدفه مصفاه للنفط في مدينه
زفروج التي نشاهدها الان على الشاشه تقع
جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا هزتها سلسله انفجارات
وفق ما افاد به مراسل الجزيره بينما اكدت
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تصديها لهجوما
صاروخي استهدف العاصمه كييف وتسبب في
اضرار ماديه نذهب جنوبا حيث تعرضت مدينه
خيرسون لهجوم الروسي اسفر عن مقتل شخصين
واصابه 25 اخرين وفق ما قالت هو كييف
جنوبا ايضا تتحدث القوات الروسيه عن صدها
لهجمات اوكرانيه في خمس مناطق قرب باخمه
وعن استهدافها لمعقل الاوكرانيه ومخازن
الاسلحه عبر ضربات صاروخيه في اتجاه
صوليدار باخموت والكساندرو كلينوسكي وايضا
قربى افديفكا هذا وتعزز روسيا قواتها
بمزيد من الجنود على مستوى جبهات الشرق
تحديدا باتجاه بخموت في الجهه الجنوبيه
تتحدث اوكرانيا عن تقدم لقواتها في جميع
المناطق والاتجاهات الى كيلو مترين في كل
اتجاه هذا وتم حاكم مقاطعه كورسك القوات
الاوكرانيه بمهاجمه قريه سالنو بخمسه
صواريخ ما الحق اضرارا بعدد من المنازل في
منطقه كورسكو وهي منطقه روسيه تقع داخل
الاراضي